c'est comme en cours mais c'est comme ça
[Musique]
on décolle à 4h30 pour être à l'aéroport
à 5h
je sais même pas si je vais en fait
[Musique]
à quelle heure
elle peut venir quand elle veut les
portes sont ouvertes
la nuit quand je me couche et je me
demandais où était-elle est-ce qu'elle
habite ici est-ce que la meilleure
[Musique]
vous venez d'assister au premier maman
d'un dénouement rêve et un conte de fée
inaccessible pour la plupart des adoptés
du Guatemala
bonjour désolé de te déranger je suis
adoptée du Guatemala et je vis en
Belgique j'ai trouvé un acte d'adoption
pour une personne adoptée par une
famille Bellanger en septembre 82
un soir de mars 2019 sur la Rive-Sud de
Montréal Josée Bélanger reçoit un
mystérieux texto d'une certaine Sophie
et lui réponds oui j'ai été au Québec en
septembre 80 de mon vrai nom est
vraiment arrêter de bah j'ai commencé
comme
ça il
est probablement sa sœur
[Musique]
j'ai j'ai su que c'était elle et je lui
ai envoyé un message tout de suite
deux femmes chacune dans son pays du
Nord se trouve des racines communes en
Amérique centrale des milliers d'autres
adultes adopter au Guatemala chercher
aussi il se demande s'ils ont été
trafiqué volé ou vendu
parce que pendant 35 ans la guerre
civile a dévasté le Guatemala
200000 personnes tu es où disparu et
beaucoup beaucoup d'orphelins
la mobilisation des
militaires en déplacer vers les villes
des enfants arrêtez ou dont les parents
avaient été tué ils se sont vite rendu
compte qu'on pouvait les données en
adoption
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est adulte adopté
cherchent leurs parents morts-vivants
Marco Garavito et son organisation les
assiste dans leurs démarches et ils
découvrent parfois ils ont été
marchander
cuando cuando dans les commerces devenue
prospère les enfants de la guerre ne
suffisait plus à la demande qui a
surpassé l'autre alors ces gens ont
commencé à recruter des jeunes filles
enceintes
au moins 50000 petits guatemaltais quand
été adopté vers l'étranger durant 30 ans
un phénomène devenu très lucratif très
rapidement rappel l'anthropologue aller
rendre à Cologne
les avocats
au top de chez le docteur les familles
d'accueil les enfants il y avait le
fonctionnaire public qui reste de
l'argent pour faire le processus passer
publique
un système de vente et de trafic
d'enfants ni sur fille pour répondre à
la demande internationale comme
plusieurs rapports l'ont confirmé
pour adopter facilement c'est au
Guatemala qu'il fallait aller parce que
les avocats contrôler tout le processus
ça veut dire que l'avocat qui représente
les parents adoptifs se présenter aussi
l'enfant et sa mère biologique ton ça
ouvre la porte pour n'importe quelle
sorte as vu des abus comme des adoptions
légal en apparence mais où l'identité et
le consentement des parents ne sont pas
toujours vérifier par l'État c'était
courant à partir des années 80 qui
n'empêche pas le Guatemala d'avoir la
côte au Québec après la Corée et à ici
c'est là que les Québécois vont le plus
souvent chercher les enfants
[Musique]
c'est la fête de bienvenue à Yoann on
fait partie de cette première vague le
couple avait déjà un fils en 1986 après
une longue attente il part en fin
chercher leur fille alors que Lina c'est
la même chose que quand le bébé sort de
ton ventre puis surtout puis tu vois ça
ensemble si j'étais j'étais en 6e
jusqu'à l'âge de l'adolescence me suis
jamais posé la question pourquoi je n'ai
pas de quoi vous êtes certaine sur votre
identité
que j'ai la peau brune les yeux bruns
que je te le fais si c'est ça c'est ça
c'est mon prénom je pense aussi c'est
mon vrai prénom est ma date de naissance
pas certainement là je ne suis
absolument certain de rien elle ne sais
pas non plus si elle a été volé vendu ou
dans le meilleur des cas abandonner ses
papiers ne contiennent aucune
information sur sa mère à l'époque ses
parents avaient fait affaire avec une
agence québécoise accrédité est bénévole
mais le bénévolat semble-t-il ça
s'arrête au Québec à la portée du
concert que moi j'écoute de donc je
l'avais apporté content donc j'avais ça
dans la ceinture vous aviez combien de
1800 ans ça fait presque 3000 dollars
transmis directement à l'avocat
guatémaltèque et on ne laisser notre
argent
là il a mis dans le coffre afin d'avoir
un nous il nous a donné une date va
chercher à l'hôtel à tout à l'heure on
va aller chercher Johan à comment vous
vous sentez pas comme ça
n'importe quoi c'est là que je t'ai
acheté c'est
pas dans mon magasin
[Musique]
avec l'encouragement de ses parents
Ioana à chercher des traces de son passé
c'est un voyage au Guatemala qu'elle a
réalisé la profondeur de la blessures
causés par les adoption de masse les
plus âgés
dès que je sais que j'avais été adopté
c'était la tristesse le regard c'était
me voyait vraiment une tristesse j'ai
perdu
dire que j'étais adopté et
en suspens
celle de Sophie et José elle ne fait que
débuter car je l'ai regardé trouver je
me suis vu en arrière je suis dans ses
yeux je me suis dans son visage puis je
me suis fait
elle s'est foulé Alvarado la mère de
Sophie en Belgique et de José au Québec
au printemps 2019 les deux femmes
continue de s'écrire et de s'interroger
sur ce qui les unit je lui ressemble
mais rien n'est certain dans ce que je
serais déçu si ce n'était pas vraiment
ma sœur
il y a toujours un micro doute faisons
confiance mais prudemment
c'est un fou ou bien dans son dossier
d'adoption belge que sa fille s'est posé
des questions on l'a décrit d'abord
comme la fille unique d'une mère
célibataire en fait j'ai découvert que
elle elle était divorcé que elle avait
déjà 3 enfants au-dessus de plus âgé que
moi et donc elle n'avait pas les moyens
financiers que pour me garder
sa fille n'était pas au bout de tes
surprises et José non plus pour en avoir
le cœur net elles devront se tourner
vers la génétique
toutes ces histoires sont surréalistes
demain on commande de test ADN sur
internet
[Musique]
après la pose une histoire d'adoption
qui tourne au cauchemar
j'ouvre la porte et je vois toi monsieur
et puis derrière eu 4 militaires avec
des mitraillettes
[Musique]
l'adoption Guatemala avait la réputation
d'être rapide facile et vous allez le
découvrir parfois une humaine on peut
comprendre que les choses sont un peu de
cross dans un pays en guerre mais ici au
Québec on ne certainement pas été
exemplaire dans la gestion des adoption
internationale
[Musique]
novembre 81 il y a 40 ans
le Guatemala est devenu un pays facile
et rapide ou adopter
et le Québec reçoit un premier coup de
semence
maintenant cette affaire d'adoption au
Guatemala et ben aujourd'hui les 4
quebecoise qui sont rendus pour adopter
des enfants elles ont été accusé de
complicité dans la falsification de
document officiel
[Musique]
ici comme là-bas l'affaire fait grand
bruit pendant des semaines on est à
l'hôtel dans notre chambre 4 femmes 5
enfants et ça frappe à la porte
elle s'appelle Monique Letellier elle
est une de celles arrêter ce jour-là
j'ouvre la porte et je vois trois
monsieur et puis derrière eu 4 militaire
avec des mitraillettes et nous on dit on
vous amène
vous avez des enfants avec vous en veux
pour questionner Monique Letellier et au
Guatemala pour ramener son fils adoptif
de presque 4 ans dans la chambre se
trouve aussi quatre bébés certains sont
destinés à des couples rester au Québec
les militaires en barque femme et enfin
vers le poste de police après 2 jours
d'interrogatoire ce qui se passe bien et
que nous on va en prison et l'heure
c'est l'heure
qui vient chercher les enfants on les
parts et
non c'est pas si on va pouvoir les
ravoir
selon les documents un policier obtenu
par un K est c'est le nombre d'enfants
en transit vers le Canada qui a attiré
l'attention de la division local
d'Interpol il y avait eu un scandale de
trafic d'enfants quelques mois
auparavant on s'est pas méfiée
effectivement alors on a pensé au on
passe comme faisant du trafic d'enfer et
là je dois vous dire quelle angoisse
[Musique]
qui est médecin s'est-elle retrouver
dans une prison guatémaltèque avec son
mari elle avait toujours souhaité
adopter un enfant à l'international mais
c'est là déjà un fils il fait face à des
années d'attente sur la liste des
services sociaux ont répondu vous avez
déjà un enfant il n'est pas question que
ce soit votre tour à cette fois-ci alors
donc là on s'est vraiment engagé dans la
voie privée elle se tourner vers les
enfants du soleil une organisation
québécoise privée non accrédité mais
surtout sans longue liste d'attente
l'organisme des enfants du soleil ne
mettez pas des enfants ou pas laisser le
libre choix aux parents de
accueillir un autre enfant
en fait elle adoptera à une vitesse
supersonique 2 enfants en moins de 4
mois au Guatemala la police commence à
se poser des questions
[Musique]
dans le rapport présenté au tribunal les
policiers d'écrivains mécanismes
d'exportation de bébés par les enfants
du soleil
les enquêteurs se soucie les contrats
d'adoption et les passeports des bébés
sur les demande de visa des enfants il
est clairement écrit touriste on se fait
prendre une certaine façon par notre
notre incompréhension des processus et
on confie la tâche des processeurs c'est
un professionnel donc c'est sûr qu'on se
fait avoir
aucun tribunal au ministère
guatémaltèque navette intérim Nice et
adoption l'avocat local Edmond mille est
considéré que la procédure n'était pas
nécessaire il est arrêté par la police
et je t'ai en prison avec les mère
biologique des enfants et ses propres
clientes tous accusé d'avoir participé à
la falsification de document officiel il
fallait sortir vivant de la société note
objectif avez-vous vraiment pensé que
vous pouviez passer plusieurs années en
prison
moi je sais pas c'est que je serai le
20h
[Musique]
ils sortiront après 2 semaines mais non
pas le droit de quitter le pays
séquestrer à l'hôtel les quebecoises
reçoivent une visite inquiétante c'est
leur avocat Edmond mulet qui a été
libéré lui aussi et nous sommes à Nasser
de ne rien faire contre lui
mais on a eu pas
quelles menaces pouvez-vous représenter
pour lui il voulait s'assurer qu'une
fois libéré en reviendrai pas contre lui
les quatre québécoise en compris le
message et le signe ce document officiel
et s'engage à ne jamais poursuivre leur
avocat Edmond mulet ni au civil ni au
pénal définitivement
j'allais signer et
suppression ça nous fait quitter et puis
je pars c'était le prix à payer
dans ce document notarié les
prisonnières s'engagent aussi à ne pas
poursuivre leur avocat québécois Jean
Francoeur c'est le conseiller juridique
des enfants du soleil au Québec et il
est au cœur des opérations
en
[Musique]
l'épouse de Jean Francoeur lise a été
arrêté au Guatemala avec sa mère et en
même temps que Monique Letellier les
deux femmes devaient ramener des enfants
au Québec pour des couples qui n'avait
pas voulu se déplacer finalement après
un mois de détention les accusations
tombent les quebecoises sont libérées
mais
ils sont restés au Guatemala alors que
Lina le temps de régulariser leur statut
les délais auront des conséquences
dramatiques pour Madame Letellier et sa
famille comme vous le verrez plus tard
on s'aperçoit que le mulet est au cœur
d'une quinzaine d'adoption
dans les années 80 et 90
Lucie Leblanc a été l'un des premier
directeur du secrétariat à l'adoption
internationale créée après le scandale
des Québécoises arrêté il se souvient de
l'énorme pression imposée par les
parents adoptifs de l'époque
c'est un la négation
de tout ce qui pouvait faire en sorte
que le besoin d'avoir un enfant attardé
on voulait pas
cette lettre que nous avons obtenu
témoin de l'attitude de l'époque
l'avocat j'en francœur propose à son
collègue Edmond mulet de place et encore
plus d'enfants guatémaltèque au Québec
en transférant les enfants à l'essai
dans un contrat de probation et ce avant
même que les parents québécois ne soit
évaluée par les services sociaux une
étape pour teint obligatoire à l'époque
[Musique]
rejoins par courriel Jean Francoeur
soutient qu'il ne s'agissait que dans le
projet jamais réalisé il n'y avoir fait
quoi que ce soit des légal ou des
régulier dans ce dossier d'adoption
en 1984 son confrère Edmond mulet et
inculpé à nouveau on l'accuse cette fois
d'avoir diriger un réseau de trafic
d'enfants vers le Canada ses accusations
sont tombés comme les précédentes maître
mulet affirme n'avoir rien fait
d'illégal et être victime d'un complot
politique il est aujourd'hui candidat
présidentielle dans son pays
après la pause on enquête avec Juana sur
les princes de ses parents
on a trouvé
un homme et une femme
[Musique]
le désir de connaître leurs origines
pour certaines personnes adopté est
tellement fort qu'elle n'hésite pas à
déployer les grands moyens des tests
d'ADN du service de recherche sur le
terrain au Guatemala et avec elle on va
découvrir la réponse qu'elle cherche
depuis si longtemps
[Musique]
les petits adopter du Guatemala sens
maintenant devenu grand il part ou au
Québec il se demande par où commencer
ici dans sa petite maison de
Saint-Jérôme. Alors cherche elle aussi
depuis 20 ans avec des documents
contradictoire où est incomplet dans mes
papiers en espagnol j'ai les deux noms
de mes parents quand on voit la
traduction en anglais on ne le seulement
le nom de ma mère mais en français ses
deux parents ils
connu. On a été adopté en 1988 à l'âge
de 2 ans et demi et dans son histoire il
y a des en troublante comme son
mystérieux transfert à l'orphelinat
après un séjour à
l'hôpital. A-t-elle été maltraité puisse
enfin de savoir est-ce que c'est
vraiment eux qui m'ont abandonné est-ce
que c'est elle qui a fait en sorte de me
prendre où est-ce que mes parents sont
envie ou si test d'ADN contact avec
l'ambassade recherche sur facebook elle
a tout essayé
[Musique]
nous prenons les choses en main à la
d'une avocate guatemalteque spécialisé
dans ce genre de recherche
[Musique]
à quelques milliers de kilomètres du
Guatemala un homme partage les mêmes
tourments
c'est dans les forêts de la Gaspésie
qu'on débarque et bon nombre de petits
guatemalteque dans les années 80
j'ai l'impression d'avoir une vie va
être deux réalités 1 1
Canada
l'histoire du mage voilà puis
même si on a son arrivée ici à Amqui
c'était en 1986 il n'avait pas encore 3
ans beaucoup de gens dans le gérant tu
as sauvé en allant chercher la
précarité donc tu nous aides mais moi
j'ai rien demandé
il était trop jeune pour se souvenir de
ce qu'il a quitté mais il n'arrive pas à
oublier ce qu'il attendait ici
il a encore pars aujourd'hui il nation a
été victime de service physique et
psychologique pendant plusieurs années
son parcours en Gaspésie c'est terminé
dans la famille d'accueil ou la DPJ la
transférer pour le protéger
depuis il cherche sa famille mais il a
l'impression de tourner en rond
mettez-vous comme dans notre classe
quand 240 télé
tu arrives au Canada
[Musique]
avec l'espoir qu'il lui reste il repart
une troisième fois vers le pays qui
n'est pas vraiment le sien
[Musique]
les journalistes annonces rarement des
bonnes nouvelles alors j'ai invité
aujourd'hui c'est une exception on a
trouvé
on a trouvé
un homme et une femme sont effectivement
s'appelle
[Applaudissements]
tu as des questions beaucoup de
questions nous avons quelques réponses
oui Juana à ses journées à l'hôpital
avec une blessure oui c'est là que leur
fait Lina et aller la chercher mais non
c'est parents n'ont jamais été soupçonné
de l'avoir maltraiter ils sont quelle
heure phelinas et l'adoption a été la
seule solution c'est de la part des
autorités
c'est qu'on leur a laissé le choix
après les choses vont vite la famille
biologique de Roanne à est impatiente de
la rencontrer et lire aller rejoindre à
la fin de l'été avec son amoureux
3000 km les préparatifs des buts
sur la Rive-Sud de Montréal en banlieue
de Bruxelles José et Sophie s'impatiente
elles attendent les résultats de leur
test génétique depuis un mois et demi
sont-elles oui ou non sœur ou demi-sœur
il leur faudrait 25 à 50 % d'ADN commun
pour le confirmer
si on est pas sœur on reste en contact
n'est-ce pas
j'ai reçu les résultats
0,2 % d'aller en commun elles sont
peut-être cousine mais de très loin je
suis déçu mais c'est pas un choc ils
nous ont bien trafiqué nos dossiers
c'est quand et donc ça a été
ça a été ça a été une claque quelque
part parce que
on savait qu'il y avait eu des traces
dans les dossiers on savait qu'avec des
fratries supposés qui existait exister
mais là c'était la preuve que
qu' y avait eu des choses palette
récapitulant sa fille fait des
recherches en Belgique elle se découvre
et d'abord trois frères et soeur elle en
trouvera finalement sept sept frères et
soeur tous un principe issu de la même
mère au moins 2 Sophie et José n'ont
aucun lien génétique
[Musique]
son rôle dans un potentiel trafic
d'enfants est-ce qu'elle a été
participants parce qu'elle était une
maman ou papa et maman 3
est-ce que où est-ce qu'elle était juste
sa fille et José sont un contact avec
Melvin le fils de l'un des autres
enfants adoptés en Belgique son ADN
pourrait-il permettre de résoudre une
partie du mystère
après la pose des retrouvailles
bouleversantes
on est là jamais donné un adoption elle
ne m'a été volé
[Musique]
vous l'aurez compris comme les documents
d'adoption contiennent plein fausseté
c'est rare que les enfants guatémaltèque
réussissent à retrouver leurs parents
mais quand le miracle se produit c'est
vraiment émouvant
[Musique]
c'est le retour de l'enfant
perdu. Reviens dans les bras de ses
parents
et dans ceux de sa sœur Ingrid
I2C nombre de mes frères et soeur
la suite est un
tourbillon. On se partage entre son père
et sa mère qui sont séparés depuis
longtemps
[Musique]
comme pour attraper trois décennies en
deux semaines
[Musique]
sac à dos avec les photos de 35
dernières années et commencer à
comprendre ce qui s'est vraiment passé
en 1985
et nous ça a été vraiment volé
un terme que les deux parents répétera
en plusieurs fois pourtant les documents
que nous avons obtenu au Guatemala sont
formelles quana a été abandonné.
non jamais jamais parce que quand je
suis arrivé à l'hôpital ma fille n'était
plus là
anna était à l'hôpital parce qu'elle
était blessé 35 ans plus tard on ne sait
toujours pas ce qui s'est passé le
nouveau conjoint de sa mère a été
soupçonné de l'avoir maltraité mais
c'est parents jamais dans les dossiers
que nous avons obtenu il est clair que
l'État ne proposait qu'une seule option
l'adoption de Roanne même si son père
avait réclamé sa garde
analphabète non profit et
nous n'avons jamais donné notre fille à
l'adoption
chacun se serait fait dire séparément
que l'autre parent avait consenti à
l'adoption est resté à l'orphelinat où
ses parents n'ont pas eu le droit de la
visiter
j'ai beaucoup pleuré on ne me laissez
pas avoir ma fille
finalement je l'ai vue de loin il était
à la fenêtre de 2e étage
lumière ne pouvais pas le savoir mais à
ce moment-là sa fille était déjà promise
a un couple du Québec
en 1988 c'est ici que les parents
adoptifs de Roanne a été venu la
chercher aujourd'hui c'est une prison
pour les délinquants endurci et les
gangs de rue les garde il est à laisser
entrer une touriste Merouana insiste
pour elle l'établissement fait partie de
son histoire j'ai vécu quand même 2
mois à peu près à 2 ans et demi si donc
c'est pas de pas savoir où est-ce que
j'ai pu marcher où est-ce que je peux
dire à quoi ça ressemble
trop dangereux on laissera parwana
passer les portes de l'ancien orphelinat
Elissa Martinez était un orphelinat
public et c'est au Canada qu'on a envoyé
le plus d'enfants issu de son programme
d'adoption
Inacio ils sont tous passés entre ses
murs mais leurs dossiers ils sont plus
ils ont été perdu détruit ou fabriquer
comme tellement d'autres archives
pendant la guerre civile
des documents de Roanne a été
suffisamment complet pour nous permettre
de trouver sa famille elle a de la
chance et elle le sait
son ami il NaCIO espère lui aussi avoir
trouvé un bon filon il a un mail le
numéro de téléphone de l'avocat qui a
réalisé son adoption
les anciens dollars US
initiation s l'avocat est-il conserver
son dossier
nous les avocats nous n'avions pas
d'information sur l'origine de l'enfant
ni sur ses parents biologiques ni rien
non simplement voilà l'enfant
l'avocat n'ira pas plus loin il n'a si
on se retrouve à nouveau bloqué dans la
recherche de ses parents et de son pays
est
comme un étranger en fait c'est toi qui
qui fait mal c'est ça qui
en fait
comme déjà dit
j'ai beaucoup
[Musique]
2 québécois se retrouve au Guatemala il
cherche la même chose mais une seule à
trouver
Quentin pour elle de plusieurs personnes
adaptées dans le mien de pouvoir un jour
retrouver à
moi
de la jalousie
je suis jaloux
j'aurais tellement aimé que ce soit moi
[Musique]
où Anna le sait et elle soutient une
nation dans sa démarche ensemble il
tapisse la ville de cet avis de
recherche enfin devenu adulte cherche
parents désespérément
presque en même temps Sofia en Belgique
et José au Québec s'apprête à lever un
nouveau pain du mystère celui de leur
supposer mère kuliah Alvarado
je suis pas prête psychologiquement je
suis pas prête
t'énerver
mais oui j'ose pas regardé le truc
le truc c'est une nouvelle preuve d'ADM
on sait déjà que les deux femmes ne sont
pas liés génétiquement mais peut-être y
a-t-il un lien avec un autre des enfants
de Julian Alvarado autrement dit ce
garçon Melvin est-il le neveu de Sophie
ou celui de José
Sophie ouvre son courriel la première je
n'ai aucun lien avec nous n'avons
détecté aucun aucun aucun
ADN entre moi et Melvyn
ce qui signifie
que nous n'avons nous ne partageons
aucun danser sur les 4 dernières
générations
donc j'ai osé est-ce que vous voulez
aller vérifier
et oui 12 ans
et toi
tu as fait quoi
avec lui OK
vous avez bien compris il n'y a aucun
lien entre - 3 des 8 enfants déclarer de
la mystérieuse Julian Alvarado qu'est-ce
que ça dit sur le processus d'adoption
de cette époque
c'était bien mal foutu
qui est
Marco Garavito allons tenter de répondre
à cette question pour son anniv Sophie
il cherche depuis des années et il n'est
pas plus avancé
bien sûr mais dans la vie elle n'existe
pas
[Musique]
au retour comment cette expérience si
riche en émotions à changer leur vie
[Musique]
à sa sortie de prison Monique Letellier
attendra longtemps son fils adoptif il
est resté à l'orphelinat au Guatemala je
l'avais connu joyeux
il marchait partout il m'a appelé maman
pour s'occuper de lui quelque chose
[Musique]
après quelques semaines il sera
finalement rester un an lorsqu'il arrive
dans sa nouvelle famille au Québec plus
rien ne va j'essaie à enroulé autour des
jambes
comme ça et
c'était 4e
on va au Mali là ça va demander
du temps pour un prêt voici
les faire comprendre
éventuellement qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
hier
j'étais j'étais souffrante
[Musique]
la greffe ne prendra jamais le petit
garçon ne réussira pas à s'attacher Nice
ta famille elle sécurisé quand tu ne
travailles au social lui propose de
changer de famille il accepte Monique
Letellier accepte elle aussi à
contrecœur tu as laissé des séquelles
c'est quand même moi quand je suis
encore eu but de soy il y a quelque
chose je dirais quelle tristesse qui
peut revenir
son avocat j'en francœur a fait l'objet
d'une enquête du syndic du barreau qui
se réveiller sans suite il a cessé de
préparer les dossier d'adoption à la fin
des années 80
le Canada a finalement interdit les
adoptions du Guatemala en 2001 en 2008
c'est le Guatemala lui-même qui ferme la
porte à toutes les adoptions
international elles n'ont pas repris
depuis
c'est la fête l'occasion pour Yohanna et
une nation de célébrer les retrouvailles
de Juana avec sa famille d'origine mais
aussi de marquer la fondation du premier
groupe de soutien au plus de 200 ans
adopter guatémaltèque du Québec et c'est
ça qui nous sommes ici
[Musique]
retrouver ma famille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]